the impact the recession has been been
mixed on the one hand and we this was a
survey that my colleagues at booz &
company undertook that we realized we
understood from us from a survey of
senior executives that many of them had
parked sustainability issues in general
you know further down the priority list
you know num you know number 11 on a
10-point list let's get through the
night let's not worry about this stuff
we've got more important things to deal
with right here and now like can we
survive that's been the negative impact
the same time what I'm seeing
simultaneously is that around some of
the cost issues here particularly some
of the cost issues and the cost
opportunities that are created in a
carbon constrained world have moved
right to the front of the pack you know
well maybe we're not going to deal on a
broad theoretical level with the company
in society and what are our
sustainability issues but boy if we can
cut our energy costs by twenty percent
in the next year we need that money now
and so a lot of that is is moving right
up in general in a recession as you know
people hold back on capital expenses so
they're much more likely to change the
lightbulbs than to actually redo the
building entirely so that it's a so that
you know it's a it's a leed gold
standard building and so on and so forth
they're going to have to be pushed in
that respect but it's kind of the same
thing you see in the auto industry you
know on the one hand the auto industry's
on the ropes on the other hand the obama
administration with the full agreement
of the industry saying let's raise cafe
standards so we're seeing the the
simultaneous you know the recession
taketh away and the recession giveth in
terms of intensity around some of these
things but cost is clearly the the the
foremost driver of sort of green
initiatives at least right now
the first thing you have to think about
is how much energy do i use what am I
paying for it and where is it coming
from because as you look at the effect
of a carbon constrained world on your
income statement you one issue is our
energy costs going to go up in general
will my price per BTU of whatever it is
go up second issue and related is even
insofar as they don't go up will they
become more volatile will they will they
you know will we see the kinds of spikes
and crashes that we saw in oil prices in
the last 12 months the answer to both of
those questions is almost certainly yes
the costs will go up and so will the
volatility the second question is will
there be a change in the energy
production mix will I be moving from oil
and hydrocarbons to renewables and solar
and so on and so forth will I be moving
from liquid fuels to electricity
electrification and so on and so forth
so that's a a second energy production
question a third question is an energy
consumption question will there be
changes in the way in which people
consume energy for example will they do
different things for transportation will
they move from you know cars to buses
will they move from airplanes two trains
will they move from you know bicycles
you know from cars to bicycles what will
the mixes in energy consumption be and
finally what are the changes in the
regulatory environment is there going to
be a track cap-and-trade system is there
going to be a carbon tax will there be
regulations and I don't mean just
emission standards but also green
building regulations will I have to do
something about the real estate i occupy
or will there be changes in what you
might call market regulations which is
my customer requirements you know
customers will not deal with me unless
IM green and that's a kind of a
regulation all of those are pretty
specific ways in which you might find an
impact on on basically on the cost
structure of your organization and you
better think it through and sort of work
your way work your way through that
checklist the other way of looking at
this is there also might be implications
on the revenue side think about the
effects of if energy prices and
transportation prices go up I think that
a company actually ought to think about
every one of its major geographies every
one of its product lines and every one
of its customer segments and say will
their behavior change and if so is that
going to affect me so there's a pretty
systematic way in which you really ought
to be looking over all of your cost and
revenue drivers